تويتر صفحه الرائحه كورونا وعاد قاده اكبر
اقتصادات العالم للقاء موعد عقد في جزيره
جبال الاندونيسيا ريهانات عالميه كبرى على
جدول اعمال قمه العشرين من ضمنها حاله
الطوارئ المناخيه وازمه الغذائي والطاقه
وتبقى الحرب في اوكرانيا القضيه الاصعب
العالميه الجديده
في ظل التوتر بين الغرب وموسكو تغيب
الرئيس الروسي عن القمه وناب عنه وزير
الخارجيه ومنعا للاحراج لم يجري التخطيط
لالتقاط صوره جماعيه للقاده المشاركين غير
ان ذلك لم يمنع الرئيس الفرنسي من دعوه
نظيره الصيني للتعاون لانهاء الحرب
ولكن هناك ايضا الازمات الدوليه الاخرى
كالحرب التي شنتها روسيا في اوكرانيا
في العالم بلدانها تشكل نحو 80% من الناتج
الاجمالي العالمي وتقوم بثلاثه ارباع
تجاره العالميه